- - Des images dans le métro, de
KiKiev. Des gens qui se réfugiet
dadans le métro de plusieurs
vivilles d'Ukraine. On parle
bebeaucoup de géopolitique, de
grgrandes manoeuvres russes il e
fafaut pas oublier qu'il y a des
gegens, qui depuis la nuit
dedernièrere, ont entendu des bs
dodoivent aller se réfugier.
PaPas perdre de vue les citoyens
susur le terrain.
StStéphanie Chouinard, Rafaël
JaJacob et Michel C. Auger.
BoBonsoir. Stéphanie je commence
avavec vous, oui on n'en parle
dedepuis trois semaines malgré
totout quand ça arrive c'est le
chchat qui la stupeur.
- - Oui on le savait depuis luni
avavec le discours de Monsieur
PoPoutine qui était sans équivoe
susur cette façon de voir
l'l'Ukraine et son manque de
rereconnaissance totale de la
sosouveraineté ukrainienne. Mais
llà o on voit que depuis hier, n
vovoit les impacts, on voit les
bobombes et les impacts non
seseulement sur la frontièrere s
auaussi sur les civils.
- - On se demande, est-ce que ls
sasanctions auront un effet?
CoComment l'Europe, comme à
WaWashington, qu'elle apporte de
sosortie ultime?
- - Absolument, et absolument à
ququel point l'Ouest et l'accidt
pepeut facilititer cette peur de
fafaire ça. Il faut dire trèss
frfranchement, la tragédie qu'on
vovoit à l laquelle on assiste
dedepuis les dernièreres heuresà
ququelque chose d'inquiétant car
ilil n'y a pas de porte de sorte
clclaire présentement. Les État-
UnUnis semblent, largement
imimpuissant. Il y avait quelque
chchose de profondément émouvant
dans le discours de Joe Biden.
OnOn parlait des idéaux
dédémocratiques, s'était senti.
QuQuand on a commencé à i interr
lele président américain sur ce
ququ'il allait réellement faire,
onon l'a vu ignorer des questios
.i.il est des questions assez
exexistantes. Les Américains, il
n'n'est aucunement question
d'd'envoyer des soldats américas
susur le terrain en Ukraine.
PrPrésentement ce condensé des
sasanctions, des sanctions qui
adadaptons eu là a aussi un effe
didissuasion pratiquement nulle.
- - Voie de sortie, est-ce qu'on
enenvoyait nous on est dans le
brbrouillard?
- - D'autant que on est dans le
brbrouillard. D'autant que la
méméthode prise par les pays
ococcidentaux, sont des sanctio.
CÇa peut peut-êtrtre marcher, ms
çaça prend du temps. Et ce n'est
papas, les sanctions sont
grgraduées. Exemple, sont vues
ututiliser l'interdiction de toe
trtransaction bancaire avec la
RuRussie, on ne fait pas ça le
prpremier jour. On vous un peu
plplus tard. Pour l'instant, ça
n'n'a pas d'effet de dissuasion
susur Monsieur Poutine. Finalemt
ilil les voyait venir. Il ne fat
papas oublier que ces sanctions
auauront des effets sur nous.
PrPrenant le prix de l'énergie
plplus élevée. Monsieur Biden a
dédéjà b beaucoup de difficultés
avavec l'inflation et le prix de
l'l'essence auaux États-Unis, en
imimposant ces sanctions là,,
c'c'était mal à l lui-mêmeme. Ie
fafaut pas l'oublier. Un moment
dodonné, ce n'est pas l'intérête
plplus solide celui des sanctio.
- - Très s rapidement, Joe Bideà
trtrois problèmemes principaux
dedepuis des mois, l'inflation,
l'l'inflation et l'inflation.
PrPrésentement, il a aucune bone
opoption pour confronter ses
prproblèmemes là. . On s'attende
hahausse encore plus marquée
dédépérit de l'énergie aux État-
UnUnis dans un contexte de défit
hihistorique aux États-Unis. La
seseule chose qu'il semble
coconsidérer comme option ce
seserait de mettre une pause sur
leles taxes sur l'essence, sauf
quque puisqu'il y a un énorme
dédéficit, la seule façon de fae
çaça c'est de faire en sorte que
lala réserve des râleles imprime
l'l'argent États-Unis, qui
cocontribuent à l l'inflation. e
lala porte-parole de la Maison-
BlBlanche lundi, le président
auaujourd'hui, il va y avoir un
cocoût t la grande question c'ee
sasavoir si un président qui a n
tataux de probation de 40 %, à a
cacapitale nécessaire pour que a
popopulation est celle de porter
cece genre de couleur. Coup là..
- - Quels sont selon vous, les
prprochaines étapes s plausible.
EsEst-ce que s'il arrive à
ininstaller un gouvernement
prprogrès s cinquièmeme, on n'ee
momoins dans un an un ami on a
ououblié, il y a eu la Crimée, a
GeGeorgie. Ou on est devant un
blblocage, puis on arrive pas
cocomment va apaiser les chose?
- - La vous me demandez de sortr
lala boule de cristal que c'estn
exexercice à c cette période. Ce
ququ'on voit actuellement c'est
cocontente d'aller chercher des
gegens qui sont prêtsts de Pout.
CeCe qu'on pourrait faire ses
imimposer des sanctions subtils
huhumains, c'est un endroit où n
n'n'est pas le non plus de la pt
dedes alliés du Canada. Est-ce e
çaça pourrait faire en sorte qun
ararrive pas ce scénario là o ùn
n'n'a pas seulement les deux
rérégions qui délaissent de
l'l'Ukraine qui sont contrôlélér
dedes rebelles prorusse mais
jujustement Kiev est tombé. On
esespèrere ne pas arriver à c ce
scscénario là..
- - Monsieur Macron, Boris
JoJohnson, Monsieur Trudeau, ont
totous dits et d'autres objets
cecertes, en tous dits c'est la
memenace la plus sérieuse la fin
dede la deuxièmeme guerre mondi.
EÊtes-vous d'accord?
- - J'ai l'impression que le
paparallèlele n'est pas tout à t
exexact, en Europe on se rapproe
dede la situation avant les anns
3030, juste avant la deuxièmeme
guguerre mondiale. On ne souhaie
papas arriver à c cette situatin
llà, , on essaie de condamner
évévidemment la crise à l la rén
enen tant que telle.
- - En amont Patrice oui, en
tetermes de risque, la réponse t
ououi. Est-ce qu'on est les deux
pipieds dedans, également que n.
MaMais est-ce qu'on est dans une
sisituation où il y a un risquee
coconflit qui déborde trèss
prprobablement très s largement
cocomment ne pas vu depuis la
dedeuxièmeme guerre mondiale en
EuEurope, personnes âgégées pera
crcroire que oui.
- - Ce n'est pas un pronostic ms
c'c'est une hypothèsese.
- - Il y a toujours un danger qe
çaça dérape. Qu'est-ce sept ans.
VoVous savez j'ai vu ça ce matin
j'j'ai pensé à l la Tchécoslova.
L'L'armée n'était pas prêtete à
réréagir contre la Russie mais l
y y avait un côtété à d dire daa
zozone d'influence il y aura le
gogouvernement que je veux.
MoMonsieur Poutine est en traine
memettre ces années où il veutÀA
cacause de ça, les autres pays
n'n'ont jamais, ne sont jamais
inintervenus en Tchécoslovaquieu
dadans la zone d'influence.
- - Parce qu'on lui accordait à
l'l'époque.
- - Oui là o on lui accorde moi,
ilil y a beaucoup de gens, allez
vovoir en France, qui disent qul
fafaut comprendre la position de
lala Russie. Beaucoup de gens ds
lele débat public disent qu'il
fafaut comprendre la position de
lala Russie. Ce n'est pas sûr,re
n'n'est pas unanimes disons en
acaccident de dire il faut aller
inintervenir et faire quelque
chchose.
- - Sanctions, est-ce qu'est-ce
ququ'on adoptait au Canada et ax
EÉtats-Unis ça fait quand mêmeme
unune différence?
- - C'est certain que si le Cana
fafait cavalier seul, il y a trs
pepeu d'impact. Sur les décisios
cocomprend. Il faut toujours que
cece soit de façon concertée. Oa
vuvu des discussions au G7 avecn
reretrait de la Russie du
prprogramme Swift, Boris Johnson
popousse très s fort dans ce cô-
llà. . Mêmeme si ce n'est pas ce
ququ'on attend de la part des
mémédias canadiens, ce stress ts
cecertainement l'une des options
susuivantes suite à c ce qui a é
anannoncé aujourd'hui.
- - Souhait c'est la messagerie
enentre les grandes banques de a
plplanètete. 11 000 banques dane
momonde. Sur les salaires et çaa
trtrès s mal.
- - En ce qui me concerne, ça
fofonctionnait, on aurait déjà .
- - On pouvait pas ne pas en
prprendre les sanctions, ça mare
dedes fois, mais ça marche
lelentement. Alors ce n'est pas
ququelque chose dans mercredi
prprochain on va dire: tiens les
sasanctions marchaient. C'est un
trtrès s long terme.
- - Quelle journée, merc